nous sommes rentrés du pérou il y a un
an pour ma part je suis actuellement en
recherche d'emploi dans le domaine des
arts et moi je suis cadre dans
l'assurance
tout a commencé par une rencontre on a
on a vécu des événements assez
douloureux pour notre famille et à cette
occasion j'ai rencontré une une personne
qui m'a parlé de fidesco et c'est un
projet qui nous a parlé tout de suite et
qui nous a permis nous aussi de nous
projeter différemment dans nos vies et
de retrouver aussi
une certaine fécondité d'une manière
différente et donc ça a été une
préparation pendant un an avec des
périodes de discernement de formation
pratique spirituelle aussi
et c'est nous qui recevant le pays de
mission est pas nous qui choisissons on
était un petit peu dans l'abandon du
pays on s'attendait un peu à tout on
s'attendait à la misère la pauvreté on
est arrivé à marseille on a l'impression
de rêver sont là l'une des parties début
septembre c'est l'hiver austral les
l'hiver là-bas s'est traduit surtout par
des nappes de brouillard plus ou moins
persistante il ya des jours où c'est
toute la journée et donc on avait
vraiment l'impression d'arriver dans cet
endroit fantomatique là on se dit ah
c'est là qu'on va passer deux ans c'est
un bide aux videurs qui est en passe de
devenir une ville vraiment du démon peut
pas vivre ici c'est pas possible ici et
bien sûr qu'on peut vivre ici et c'est
presque même insultant de dire qu'on
peut pas venu ici parce qu'il ya des
gens qui vivent ici donc faut arriver à
retrouver l'être humain la joie la joie
les la même dans une maison en bois ou
dans un château vaut finalement
notre aîné qu'il y avait quelques
appréhensions par rapport à la mission
il faut enfin moi il est lé tout un tas
de fantasmes dans la tête s'est vu qu'il
nous apportait ses deux premiers avoir
été à l'école il y a été dans les trois
jours on est arrivé il trouve ça super
et commençait à parler en espagnol à se
faire des amis vont en plus c'était le
petit blanc un peu star et son énergie
son positivisme son enthousiasme nous a
vraiment porté parce que
si eux mêmes avaient été pas bien je
pense que ça nous aurait alourdi
considérablement
moi j'étais professeur d'art dans le
collèges et lycées de munch est le plus
gros en fait qui est un collège qui
dépend de la paroisse qui est très
présente à man show et l'autre partie du
mythe ans était dans une école pour
enfants handicapés d'une quarantaine
d'enfants donc c'était une petite école
qui avait des conditions très précaires
et qui était collé à ce gros collège
la majeure partie des missions c'était
un projet avec ses palmes and live et
avec un projet de sensibilisation à
l'environnement auprès des élèves des
lycées et collèges de man shay est
concrètement de projet de réutilisation
des eaux usées donc par les méthodes
naturelles de phytoépuration
alain serge qui arrose le désert
là tu vois des gros tuyau d'alimentation
pilar salaires petit tuyau les petites
lignes d'irrigation
il ya quand même des moments quand
j'étais dans ma dent dans ma colline
tout seul avec mes bottes enfoncé dans
la dans le sable est en train de tailler
mes armes je me disais mais moi je suis
parti pour
vivre avec l'autre là je suis tout seul
dans ma colline c'était pas du tout ça
le truc enfin il ya quand même eu des
moments enfin j'étais content ça me
plaisait bien mais des moments de
solitude quand même je me disais mais
est ce que je suis vraiment parti en
mission la fin ça me plaît ce que je
suis en train de faire mais est-ce que
je suis parti en mission
comme on parlait pas du tout espagnol on
avait ce fils de la liturgie qu'on
gardait et pendant c'est extrêmement
précieux pour prier et communier avec
les marginaux pendant la messe et du
coup c'est devenu précieux pour nous
cette liturgie ou même quand on va à un
baptême et qu'on répète ces mêmes
paroles ça a pris une autre dimension en
fait
voilà qui est de l'ordre du religieux et
du lien
qui était assez intéressant ses trois
soeurs du perpétuel secours elles nous
ont accompagnés elles ont veillé sur
nous ça a été mon ami nos confidente nos
camarades de jeu nos soeurs nos mères
nos amis et puis qui notre perpétuel
secours vraiment l on était là dans les
grands et des petits moments ça a été le
vrai premier grand cadeau de la mission
de cette rencontre pendant ces deux ans
on a pris conscience un petit peu de ce
qui nous rend des riches et ce qui nous
rendait pauvres on va avoir une
perception a priori de la richesse qui
va être dans l'avoir pouvoir dépenser
pouvoir et voilà et c'est vrai que c'est
important
avoir suffisamment à manger ça permet de
se projeter dans l'avenir maintenant
quand on part qu'on laisse sa vie
confortable française et qu'on parle
d'eux ans au pérou on reste riche quand
même en fait on a appris on a découvert
un petit peu ça sur nous mêmes en ce qui
fait de nous des gens riches ça va plus
être dans la voir en fait c'est vraiment
dans l'être c'est sincèrement l'homme
peut vivre de pas grand chose à partir
du moment où voilà il ya cette structure
et une hygiène de vie
et l'amour de ses parents et cette
considération des autres
voilà ça suffit pour grandir